anger and resentment towards partner in
first trimester so I would say try anger
and resentment towards your partner
throughout the entire pregnancy I think
that's really normal so how do you
counteract that now I avoid resentment
by
overcommunication then you can avoid the
anger and resentment now there's still
going to be some anger normally I'm not
volatile I'm very volatile right now
ideally your partner can help walk you
through ways to fix whatever you're
freaking out about and not just belittle
you for being an anxious mess before you
have a baby try to make sure your
partner's on board with walking you
through things you're going to be angry
and stressed out about because pregnant
women are crazy